>> Trace: ALL RIGHT.
BORDER CROSSINGS ARE BOOMING,
BUT GET ALOAD OF THIS.
WHEN IT COMES TO DEPORTATIONS,
THEY'RE NOT.
THEY'RE AT A RECORD LOW.
WHAT GIVES?
CHAD WOLF IS THE FORMER ACTING
DHS SECRETARY.
SECRETARY, I HAVE NEVER SEEN A
CHASM LIKE THIS IN MONTHLY DATA.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> WELL, NEIL, WHAT I WILL TELL
YOU, I'M NOT SURE THE NUMBERS
ARE THAT SURPRISING FOR THOSE OF
US THAT FOLLOW IT.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU TIE
THE HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ARRESTS GO DOWN AND DEPORTATIONS
GO DOWN.
WHAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
DID IN THE EARLY DAYS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IN JANUARY,
ISSUED GUIDANCE TO ICE, LAW
ENFORCEMENT, REALLY RESTRICTING
THEM ON WHO ARE THE TYPES OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY CAN TARGET
FOR REMOVAL.
SO NOW UNDER THAT GUIDANCE, YOU
HAVE TO BE A TERRORIST OR A
SUSPECTED TERRORIST OR YOU HAVE
TO BE A CONVICTED FELON,
AGGRAVATED FELON.
THAT TAKES ABOUT 80 TO 90% OF
ALL THE TARGETS OFF THE TABLE
FOR ICE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
SO YOU SEE THE RESULT OF THAT IN
THE DATA, THE NUMBERS THAT YOU
JUST SHOWED.
NUMBERS AND ARRESTS AND
DEPORTATIONS ARE DOWN ACROSS THE
BOARD.
>> Neil: WHAT IS ODD ABOUT THIS,
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN BARACK
OBAMA WAS PRESIDENT THAT SOME
GROUPS CALLED HIM THE DEPORTER
IN CHIEF AND DIDN'T LIKE THE
RATE IN WHICH HE DEPORTED THOSE
THAT CROSSED THE BORDER OR AT
THE BORDER.
HIS VICE PRESIDENT AT THE TIME
SUPPORTED THAT EFFORT.
NOW HE'S PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
HE IS NOT CONTINUING THAT
EFFORT.
I WONDER WHAT YOU MAKE OF THAT.
>> WELL, A COUPLE OF THINGS.
I THINK WHAT IS MOST CONCERNING
IS OBVIOUSLY WE SEE THE
SITUATION GOING ON AT THE BORDER
NOT ENFORCING THE RULE OF LAW ON
THE BORDER.
NOW WE ARE ALSO SEEING THEM NOT
ENFORCING THE RULE OF LAW IN THE
INTERIOR OF THE UNITED STATES.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT ICE
COMES ACROSS, TARGETS OR COMES
INTO CONTACT WITH.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
NO LEGAL RIGHT TO REMAIN HERE IN
THE U.S.
MOST CASES THEY'VE GONE THROUGH
ADIEU PROCESS AND ORDERED TO BE
REMOVED.
SO ICE IS EFFECTUATING THAT
ORDER.
FOR THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
OFFICIALS AT DHS TO TELL THEM TO
IGNORE THE LAW, IT PUT LAWS
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN A VERY,
VERY DICEY SITUATION WHERE THEY
HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR
CAREER AND FOLLOWING THAT ADVICE
OR ADHERING TO THE RULE OF LAW
AND WHAT THEY SIGNED UP TO DO TO
ENFORCE THE LAW.
>> Neil: WE DO KNOW THAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT, KAMALA HARRIS,
INTENDS TO GO TO MEXICO TO GET
WHAT SHE SAYS IS THE START AND
WHAT CAUSES THE ROOT CAUSES OF
THIS.
PART OF THAT WILL INVOLVE GIVING
BILLIONS TO THAT NECK OF THE
WOODS.
TALKING BEYOND MEXICO, CENTRAL
AMERICA.
WE DON'T KNOW ALL THE DETAILS
YET, SECRETARY.
WE KNOW ENOUGH THAT A LOT OF
MONEY WILL BE INVOLVED.
I'M WONDERING WHETHER THAT WILL
DO THE TRICK.
ARE YOU WORRIED IT'S GOOD MONEY
AFTER BAD?
>> I'M CERTAINLY CONCERNED.
I THINK YOU CERTAINLY NEED TO
PUT A NUMBER OF STRINGS ATTACHED
TO THAT FUNDING.
YOU CAN'T PROVIDE IT TO THEM
WITHOUT ANY RETURN ON INVEST
MEANT FOR THE U.S.
THAT'S WHAT WE DID UNDER THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
WE HELD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
DOING THE THINGS THAT THEY SAID
THEY WOULD DO WITH THE FUNDING.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE SIGNED
14 DIFFERENT SECURITY AGREEMENTS
WITH THEM.
BUT THAT ALONE IS NOT GOING TO
DO IT.
SO THE IDEA AND THE STRATEGY
THAT I'M LOOKING AT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ENCOURAGING
MEXICO AND THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE
TO DO MORE TO ENFORCE THEIR
BORDERS.
YET THEY'RE NOT ENFORCING LAW ON
OUR SOUTHWEST BORDER, ON OUR OWN
BORDER THAT IS CONCERNING.
THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE TO SEE
NUMBERS THAT WE SAW IN MARCH AND
WE SEE IN APRIL, CONTINUE TO
COME ACROSS THAT BORDER IF WE
DON'T ENFORCE THE RULE OF LAW ON
THE BORDER.
YOU CAN DO ALL YOU WANT AND YOU
CAN PROVIDE FUNDING TO THE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE.
IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE, THOSE
NUMBERS WILL CONTINUE TO COME.